the 58th plenary meeting of the general
smd is called to order
before proceeding further i would like
to remind members of the following
mitigation measures
that are in place for this meeting
all delegates are required to wear a
mask or a face covering at all times
whilst in public space and in the
general assembly hall except when
directly addressing the meeting
and the size of the delegation for
member states observer states
and the european union should not exceed
four persons
and for other observers one person in
the in the hall
due to the temporary closure of the east
side emergency doors in the event of a
fire or an emergency which requires an
evacuation
please use them should not exceed four
persons
and for other observers one person in
the in the hall
due to the temporary closure of the east
side emergency doors
in the event of a fire or an emergency
which requires an evacuation
please use the west side emergency doors
in the stairway next to the elevator
banks
those in the third and fourth balconies
please use the stairway next to the
elevator banks
the general assembly will consider item
67 entitled
the situation in the temporarily
occupied territories of ukraine
mr secretary general distinguished
delegates
dear colleagues
to save succeed in generations from the
scourge of war
amongst the first very words of the jew
and charter
in its preamble
and those words were the main motivation
for creating the united nations
whose founders had lived through the
devastation of two world wars by 1945.
the united nations hold as its mandate
article 1 of the charter of the united
nations
that disputes or situations in which
peace may be broken shall be settled by
peaceful means and in conformity with
justice in the principles of
international law
it is therefore
one of the purpose of the united nations
to maintain peace and security in
accordance with the rule of law
in the last 76 years of the existence of
the united nations
it has taught us if it has thrown us
anything
then it is that
the lasting peace is not achieved nor
sustained by military engagements but
through political solutions
and the most effective way to diminish
human suffering and the massive economic
costs of conflicts
and their aftermath
is to prevent conflicts in the first
place
my dear colleagues
let's deploy the tools that we have to
resolve disputes let's give priority to
diplomacy good offices and mediation
let's give peace all the chance it
deserves
full commitment to the united nations
charter its purposes and its principles
is the only part to ensure lasting peace
i call on all parties to intensify their
negotiations
and de-escalate the current trajectory
through dialogue
i would like to conclude my statement by
courting former secretary general doug
hammershot who 68 years ago said
that the united nations was not created
to
take mankind to heaven
but to save humanity from hell
i thank you
i now give the floor to the
secretary-general of the united nations
his excellency antonio guterres
mr president of the general assembly
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
we meet in the face of the most serious
global peace and security crisis in
recent years
and certainly in my time as secretary
general
our world is facing a moment of peril
i truly hoped it would not come
the latest developments regarding
ukraine are a cause of grave concern
and they include reports of increased
ceasefire violations across the contact
line
and the real risk of further escalation
on the ground my thoughts are with all
those who have already suffered so much
deaths destruction and displacement
the history of this conflict is complex
and at least two permanently opposing
narratives
i know that their authors will never
agree on what happened in the past
but in the present situation one thing
is clear
the decision of the russian federation
to recognize the so-called independence
of the donetsk and luansk regions and
the follow-up
are violations of the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of ukraine
and inconsistent with the principles of
the charter of united nations
and here in this hallowed hall
i must emphasize that this action is
also inconsistent with the landmark
resolution adopted by the general
assembly more than half a century ago
i refer to the declaration on principles
of international law concerning friendly
relations and cooperation among states
in accordance with the charter of united
nations
this so-called friendly relations
declaration was adopted during the
general assembly session marking the
25th anniversary of the united nations
and the friendly relation declaration
which has been cited repeatedly by the
international court of justice as
representing international law
sets out several vital principles that
are highly relevant to today's session
in particular i would note the principle
of sovereign equality of states and the
affirmation that the territorial
integrity and political independence of
the state
are invaluable
other resolutions of general assembly
are also fully behind the sovereignty
political independence and territorial
integrity of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
mr president
the minsk agreements approved by the
security council and that i strongly
supported from the beginning
were surviving in an intensive care unit
thanks to a number of life support
devices
but now those devices have been
disconnected
we must also be concerned about
preserving the integrity of peacekeeping
the united nations has a long and
recognized experience deploying
peacekeeping operations which only take
place with the consent of the host
country
mr president it's time for restraint
reason and de-escalation
there is no place for actions and
statements that would take this
dangerous situation over the abyss
it's time to establish a ceasefire and
return to the passive dialogue and
negotiations
to save the people in ukraine and beyond
from the squad of war
i urge all parties to make full use of
article 33 of the charter and its
diverse instruments of pacific
settlement of disputes
mr president the united nations system
is continuing to support the people in
ukraine through our human rights and
humanitarian work
our human rights monitoring mission has
seven offices throughout the country on
both sides of the contact line
documenting civilian casualties
monitoring freedom of movement and
reporting on allegations of human rights
violations
our humanitarian operations are
independent
of whoever might control the territory
where people are living
even before this latest escalation
two million people in ukraine needed
humanitarian assistance and since the
start of 2022 alone we and our partners
have delivered 140 metric tons of
life-saving aid across the contact line
here again our actions are based
entirely on humanitarian principles
endorsed by the general assembly united
nations humanitarian assistance is
guided by four humanitarian principles
humanity neutrality impartiality and
independence
and these priorities are central to
establishing and maintaining access to
affected people
including those in the context of
unarmed conflict
the general assembly has repeatedly
underscored the importance of promoting
and respecting these principles within
the framework of humanitarian assistance
our humanitarian agencies are committing
to staying and delivering to support the
people in ukraine
and are ready to readjust and
re-prioritize their operations as
necessary
as we sadly know all too well in
conflict civilians including women and
children always suffer first and suffer
most
if the conflict in ukraine expands
the world could see a scale and severity
of need and seen for many years
i draw sides to allow safe and unimpeded
access by humanitarian agencies
including in non-government-controlled
areas of eastern ukraine
all parties must uphold their
obligations and the international
humanitarian law mr president i'm fully
committed to support all efforts to
resolve this crisis without further
bloodshed
my good offices remain available
we cannot and will not relent
in the search for a peaceful solution
thank you
i thank the secretary general for his
statement
i now give the floor to the
distinguished
foreign minister
his excellency dimitro coleba minister
for foreign affairs of ukraine
president
secretary general
i'm grateful for your leadership
in this main policy making and
representative
organ of the united nations
mr president you have chosen the word
hope as a motto for your presidency
the same feeling currently dominates
the mindsets of ukrainians and people
around the globe
hope for peace
hope
for common sense to prevail
hope
for diplomacy to ease tensions
however
today we need much more than hope
we need swift
concrete
and resolute
actions
a new type of actions by the united
nations and international community
which is relevant
to the level of the threat we all
not just ukraine
face today because of russia's
aggressive course
the people of ukraine need these actions
by ukraine's strategic partners
and international community
we are at a critical juncture in world
history
and our actions today define it for
decades to come
we all read history books
we all watched movies about the mistake
and politicians made in the run-up to
1914 and 1939
about the feats
of our grandparents
and the catastrophic price at which a
revanchist evil in europe was defeated
there is no more important task today
than to not repeat the mistakes of the
past
i do believe in the power of the free
world and our joint ability
to avert a new devastating catastrophe
in europe
that no nation will be able to sit out
this is why today i address you on
behalf of over 40 millions of ukrainians
who only wish
to live in peace
and prosperity
not in fear
intimidation
not under russian fire
bombs
and shelling
we are currently at the middle of the
largest security crisis in europe since
the second world war
this crisis was created and is being
escalated by one side unilaterally
by the russian federation
russia's accusations of ukraine are
absurd
ukraine has never threatened or attacked
anyone
ukraine has never planned and does not
plan any such action
ukraine
has never planned and does not plan any
military offensive in the donbas
neither any provocations or acts of
sabotage
it is ultimately absurd to suggest that
ukraine could have prepared for anything
like this and waited for months until
russia amassed an enormous military
force along our borders to proceed with
such alleged plans
this absurdity defies basic logic
not less absurd are accusations of
ukraine escalating
by acquiring defensive weapons from its
partners
the only
i want to stress it the only reason for
ukraine to boost its defenses
is russia's ongoing and planned military
and political actions
russia's actions and statements are
outrageous horrific and go far beyond
threatening ukraine
in fact in his address this week russian
president vladimir putin overtly denied
ukraine's right to exist
anyway anyone who might think i
exaggerate as the ukrainian foreign
minister
should just watch this horrifying speech
it is with a heavy heart that we all
need to admit
the grim reality of a new aggressive
and ravencist rule
rising over europe
this is the fourth time
[Music]
that the general assembly debates the
situation in the temporarily occupied
territories of ukraine
however this is the first time we debate
the situation in the new reality
created by the illegal recognition of
two territories of ukraine
by russia
and the backdrop of our discussion today
is much more dangerous as russia
attacked the very fundamental principles
of international peace and security
the pillars of the united nations
and as i mentioned the very existence of
the ukrainian state a founding member of
the united nations
ukraine that signed the u.n charter in
san francisco in 1945
and made the principle enshrined in
article 2 of the charter
a cornerstone of its foreign policy
a state
that voluntarily gave up its nuclear
arsenal under the security assurances of
nuclear powers
a state that has endured years of
assault by one of these powers
a permanent member of the united nations
security council
two days ago
on february 21st the russian president
recognized so-called independence
of the temporarily occupied parts of the
donetsk and lugansk regions of ukraine
and ordered the deployment of the
russian armed forces in these areas
this is an unfront attack on the united
nations
and core principles of international law
an ultimate blow
to years of peace process
and russia's unilateral withdrawal
from the minsk agreements
what is happening right now in eastern
ukraine
where russian tanks are rolling in
and along the ukrainian borders where
russian forces are amassed in enormous
quantities
must be a concern
for everyone
for all of you
i warn every nation in this
distinguished chamber
no one will be able to sit out this
crisis if president putin decides that
he can move forward with his aggression
against ukraine
your governments
and your people
will face
painful consequences together with our
government
and our people
this is why we need to use this last
chance for action and stop russia where
it is
it is clear
that president putin
will not stop by himself
distinguished representatives
the beginning of a large-scale war in
ukraine
will be the end
of the world order as we know it
if russia does not get a severe swift
and decisive response now
this will mean a total bankruptcy of the
international security system and
international institutions which are
tasked with maintaining the global
security order
this is a grim scenario which will throw
us back to the darkest times of the 20th
century
russia will not stop at ukraine
if a permanent member of the u.n
security council succeeds in breaking
literally all rules
other actors will be inspired by him and
follow his pattern
what he tries to do now
is to prove that the united nations are
weak
indecisive and unable to defend their
core principles
that rules do not apply to him to russia
to putin
what role for the united nations
does russia see
a new league of nations
we must deny russia what it wants
i graduated from the university with a
degree in international law
and strong belief in multilateralism
many years after practicing diplomacy i
still do believe in both
rules containing aggression
and the power of our collective and firm
action
if the united states
sorry the united nations make a pivot
right now to become a strong and
proactive player
which is not afraid of resolute actions
and using all of its might and powers
i am confident that russia will
stop
in this context i welcome yesterday's
statement by the united nations
secretary general
which is truly different in toad
we need decisive actions of the same
kind to follow these right words
russia shows signs of
readiness to further escalate its
aggression against ukraine and we have
limited time to stop
deter
and contain it
every hour of inaction now is a threat
to the lives of ukrainians
not only military but also civilians
including women and children
this is an escalating threat to our
collective global security and to our
freedom
expects decisive immediate and
proportional actions by the
international community
the united nations is the organization
that has to demonstrate leadership
not just condemnations
concrete actions to stop the russian
machine of war without stepping into a
bloody conflict with many thousands of
casualties
devastation
and suffering
i do not want this
ukraine doesn't want this
the world doesn't want this
we need your help right now to stop
russia from proceeding with its
aggressive plans
ukraine believes in diplomacy
we see no alternative
to peaceful solutions by political and
diplomatic means
there is still an opportunity for
diplomacy to say its worth even as
russia continues as its escalation and
provocations
for months russia pretended to pursue
diplomacy while bringing more and more
troops to our borders
and in the temporarily occupied
territories of ukraine
now this number stands at least at 150
000.
under the oec vienna document on
confidence and security building
measures
such actions fall under the
qualification of unusual military
activities
that would require explanation
however russia has persistently refused
to provide it
instead it proceeded with threats
russia has literally stuffed the black
sea and the sea of azov with at least 46
military vessels
it routinely closes large parts of the
seas under the pretext of holding naval
exercises
in practice
it amounts almost to a blockade of
ukrainian seaports
this is already an attack on the global
freedom of navigation one of the sacred
principles of international law
russia's propaganda machine is in full
swing
it desperately tries to create a pretext
for further aggression against ukraine
we resolutely reject all russian
intimidations about any alleged
ukrainian offensive military operations
in donbas
we do not hold or plan
any such actions
we remain committed to political and
diplomatic settlement
and together with our partners we
maximize efforts to reduce tensions
and keep the situation
in line with diplomatic dialogue
for now we see that russian occupation
forces have already significantly
increased shelling of ukrainian
territory and civilian infrastructure
artillery fire
at the contact line in the donbas
from the occupied territory hit a
kindergarten
in a town called stanisla luhanska
and a school
in rubika
among the latest terrible examples
recognition of the so-called republics
has no legal implications
it merely confirms russia's own
involvement as a party to the armed
conflict in donbas which russia
we hemmently denied all these years
the situation in the occupied donbass
has already been terrible for years with
residents living in the atmosphere of
fear
lawlessness and insecurity
the infamous secret prison called
izolatia
in the occupied donetsk
remains inaccessible for human rights
and humanitarian missions
it continues to function
as a literal concentration camp
in europe
in the 21st
century
hundreds of people have passed through
this camp
and were subjected to heavy forced labor
humiliation tortures
cases of extrajudicial killings have
been reported too
russia continues to block the release of
the illegally detained persons
in september 2029 the president of
ukraine voladimerzelenski
handed over to the secretary general the
list
of more than a hundred ukrainians from
donbas and crimea
who had been unlawfully detained
sentenced or even transferred from the
occupied territories to the russian
federation
we reiterate our call on the secretary
general to provide to provide good
offices and facilitate their immediate
release and i appreciate the readiness
of the secretary general
to do so
mr president
today
ukraine defends not only global security
but also freedom
democracy
and fundamental principles of
international law
peaceful life
and the future of millions of people in
europe
and around the globe rely on the rules
that russia tries to destroy
diplomacy and international forum must
prevail and stop
the russian aggression
since 2014 the general assembly has
already adopted 11 resolutions
reaffirming its commitment to ukraine's
territorial integrity and condemning the
temporary occupation of ukraine's
territories by russia
the general assembly has not and will
not accept the russian mantra
that
the case of crimea is closed end of
quote
the occupying power persists in
destroying the identity of ukrainians
and the indigenous people of the
peninsula the crimean tatars
since 2014 more than 64 000 ukrainian
citizens have had to leave crimea and
moved to mainland ukraine due to fear
persecution for political and human
rights activism discrimination on ethnic
and religious grounds
political persecutions continue unabated
among many others
mr nariman jalal david head of the
majlis of the crimean tatar people
participant of the international crimea
platform summit
remains behind bars
he is one of the
of this one more than 100 political
prisoners of the kremlin
on february 16 a court in symforopol
sentenced journalist vladislav yesipenko
on trumped up charges to six years in
prison
he is one of 14 ukrainian journalists
kept by russians in prison
russia may continue to pretend it
doesn't violate any international norms
and principles
yet
reports by the u.n security secretary
general
office of the high commissioner for
human rights always see
their missions as well as the report of
the international criminal court
prosecutor
all testify to the contrary
if russia doesn't agree with all the
mentioned resolutions and reports
it should simply provide access to
crimea
to the united nations human rights
monitoring mission in ukraine
and the oec special monitoring mission
the access of international
organizations to the occupied
territories is critical
ukraine guarantees such success
throughout the government-controlled
territory and continues to demand from
the russian side to do the same
in the occupied territories
esteemed members of the general assembly
the whole world witnesses today that
russia turns to threatening and
blackmailing the global community
to close the crimea case
end of quote
it is in fact one of the points in the
long list
of its recent so-called security demands
ukraine continues efforts to achieve the
occupation of crimea by peaceful means
the crimea platform is a tool designed
exactly for that end
we are truly thankful to all the
countries supporting the international
crimea platform
your active involvement in the platform
is a sound foundation for our future
success
we are open to new members and i call on
you to join
the crimea platform
be it states or international
organizations you are welcome
we expect the united nations will find
proper modalities to engage with this
initiative established on the principles
of the un charter
mr president
dear colleagues
ukraine
made a historic contribution to global
security
in
1994
we
denuclearized giving up the world's
third largest nuclear arsenal
we have no plans to regain nuclear
weapons
today we expect the world
reciprocally
to ensure our security
with relevant scale and resoluteness of
actions in the face of a historic level
of threat
this is the reason why ukraine requested
urgent consultations under article 6 of
the budapest memorandum
the world owes ukraine
its security
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
initiated a new format of negotiations
to settle the security crisis created by
russia
five permanent members
of the united nations security council
plus ukraine germany and turkey
this is the format that we are trying to
convene
i reaffirm
that ukraine
proposed
some years ago to deploy a u.n
peacekeeping mission to ukraine
until now united nations security
council has failed
to take necessary decisions
ukraine proposes to combine stark
sanctions policy and strengthening of
ukraine together with keeping diplomatic
channels open to persuade russia to
de-escalate and prioritize diplomacy
we urge member states to use all
available means to protect ukraine and
deter russia
whatever action you can take
is appreciated
we are grateful for the actions already
taken
by many of you
we expect the international community to
do
its best to put out the fire in the
center of europe which is about to flare
up
the russian security crisis must end
with russia returning to the passive
diplomacy
we call on all states and international
organizations
not to recognize any alteration of the
statutes of the certain areas of the
donetsk and lugansk regions of ukraine
and to refrain from any action of deal
or dealing
that might be interpreted as recognizing
any such altered status
the absence of proper reaction
or initial stance
will only contribute to further
escalation and sufferings
and
i regret to say it it will not be
limited to ukraine's border and
territory
on the contrary
active diplomacy strong political
messaging tough economic sanctions and
strengthening ukraine can still force
moscow to abandon aggressive plans
swift and resolute actions by the united
nations can reclaim the organization's
leading role
at this historic
and dark moment
russia must withdraw its forces from the
sovereign territory of ukraine
russia must stop destabilizing the
international security situation
we ukrainians want peace
and we want to resolve all issues
through diplomacy
we stand ready for all possible
scenarios and ready to protect our land
and our people if russia fill the
attacks
ukraine will not hesitate
to exercise its inherent right of
self-defense
as outlined in article 51 of the charter
of the united nations
in response to the armed attacks of the
russian federation
these days we have
probably the last window of opportunity
to do what russia does not expect the
united nations
and its member states to do
demonstrate unprecedented ability and
readiness to act in order to stop
aggression
no matter
what relations you develop among each
other
it is your
ultimate duty
to defend
the charter
the charter of the united nations
i thank you
i thank the minister for foreign affairs
of ukraine
now i give the floor to his excellency
lord ahmed minister for south asia north
africa the united nations
and the commonwealth at the foreign
commonwealth and development office of
the united kingdom
mr president
secretary general your excellencies
the united kingdom
is unwavering in its support
for ukraine's sovereignty
independence
and territorial integrity
we stand with the people of ukraine
we stand with their right to determine
their own future
president putin's decision to recognize
the so-called
don x people republic and luhans
people's republic
as independent states
proves beyond doubt
that russia has chosen the path of
confrontation
over the path of diplomacy and dialogue
mr putin has ordered his troops into
ukrainian territory
this amounts to a further invasion of
ukraine
mr president at every step
russia has rebuffed
offers of diplomacy
and indeed discarded its international
commitments
commitments it has itself agreed and
signed up to
rather it has pursued a campaign
to redraw
ukraine's internationally recognizedly
recognized borders by force
it is vital
that we the united nations the
international community must respond
we must understand the grave nature of
where we are today
and together we must call on russia to
uphold the very founding principles of
this the united nations
establish precisely
as you said yourself mr president to end
the scourge of war
peace
must
we must highlight the human cost and
respond to the humanitarian consequences
of any further russian military action
we know this will take a terrible toll
on ukrainians
but also
it will take a toll on russians alike
both victims of an unnecessary war of
the kremlin's choosing
and it's therefore essential
that we must meet russia's aggressive
acts
with solidarity with strength
including through coordinated sanctions
to impose a severe cost
on russian interests and their economy
yesterday the united kingdom
announced new sanctions
targeting billions of russian assets
this is the largest sanctions package
against russia in british history
and it is part of our coordinated
actions sanctions effort alongside our
allies
but mr president we are clear
that acting together with our allies
this is just the start
if russia
continues its campaign of aggression
we have a further package of sanctions
ready to go
we urge the wider international
community to join us in this effort
the kremlin must understand the strength
of the world's condemnation of president
putin's war of choice
mr president let us pause for a moment
let us reflect
this very week marks eight years
eight years since russia's illegal
annexation of crimea
and the city of sevastopol
it also marks eight years since russia's
forcibly seized ten thousand square
miles of sovereign ukrainian territory
in flagrant violation of international
law and russia's own
international commitments
and it's also
eight years since we the general
assembly of the united nations
recalled through resolution 68 262
the obligations of all states
under article 2 of the u.n charter
to refrain from the threat or use of
force
against the territorial integrity or
political independence of any state of
the united nations
yet eight years on
tragically
here we are again
confronted by russian aggression against
the sovereignty of ukraine
and as secretary general antonio
gutierrez has made clear
russia's unilateral measures conflict
directly with the very principles of the
united nations charter
their actions are a fundamental
challenge to global peace and security
and a challenge to the international
order on which we all rely
and equally important
it is for all of us to protect
we must condemn unequivocally
this aggression together
and stop president putin's expansionist
ambitions
mr president we must hold russia true to
its commitments under the u.n charter
and say to russia very clearly pull back
choose peace not war
whilst also
sending a very clear message to the
people of ukraine
that in your hour of need
we the international community we the
united nations stand with you
thank you
i thank the minister for south asia
north africa the united nations and the
commonwealth at the foreign and
commonwealth development office of the
united kingdom
i now give the floor to his excellency
tobias linda minister of state for the
federal
foreign office of germany
mr president excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
we meet today in a time of challenge
a couple of days ago the president of a
member state of this organization
put into question the state of of
another distinguished member of this
organization
he said and i quote
ukraine actually never had stable
traditions of statehood unquote
we must take this sentence very
seriously
some important questions arise
what does it mean for this organization
if one state construes the existence
of another state as a regrettable
accident of history thereby questioning
its right to exist
what does it mean for a common objective
of promoting peace and development
if more countries tried to roll back
history in a similar way
what does it mean for the multilateral
rules based order
if states think they can
due to their own view of history
domineer over other states and put them
under tutelage
we still do not have answers to all of
these questions
what is clear already now
russia's decision to recognize the
self-proclaimed so-called people's
republics of donetsk and luhansk could
be a deadly blow for the international
rules-based order
for the way this organization has
functioned over the last decades
russia is violating the core principles
of the u.n charter we need to close
ranks and strongly reject such action
if not
then what has hit ukraine today
could happen to other u.n member states
tomorrow
everybody in disassembly should be aware
of this
it is therefore with utmost gratitude
that we took note of the secretary
general's words he said
the principles of the u.n charter are
not manual account they cannot be
applied collectively
member states have accepted them all and
they must apply them all
ladies and gentlemen there is nothing to
add to these crystal clear words
russia's irresponsible and provocative
provocative action comes at a time
of a massive military buildup alongside
ukraine's borders
we have seen a concerning flare-up of
ceasefire violations along the line of
contact
we have witnessed a disturbing flow of
disinformation and false flag operations
meant to create pretexts for military
incursion
this time of increased tensions where
people's lives are at risk
would have been the time to go for
de-escalation to heed the securities
council repeated calls for diplomatic
efforts
instead
russia choose to again attack ukraine's
serenity and territorial integrity eight
years after russia had illegally ceased
and annexed crimea
the general assembly condemned this year
and charter violation
and it should do so again
ladies and gentlemen mr president
i commend ukraine's continued restraint
in the face of this aggression
president zielenski's commitment to
finding a peaceful diplomatic way out
since 2014 france and germany have done
their utmost to work towards a political
solution of the conflict in eastern
ukraine on the basis of the minsk
agreements
russia's signature
is under these agreements
over the last weeks
chancellor false and my foreign minister
bierbach have left no stone unturned to
engage with russia diplomatically
in close coordination with our french
partners
we are willing to chart a way forward
strengthening trust stability and
security in europe we have the framework
established to do this
in the nato-russia council in the oce
and in the normandy format
the ceasefire in the donbass must be
observed immediately
we condemn the use of heavy weaponry and
this indiscriminate shelling of civilian
infrastructure which constitutes a clear
violation of the minsk agreements
this must stop
we commend the oce special
representative for trying to convene an
extraordinary session of the trilateral
contact group
france ukraine and my country stand
ready for another meeting
in the normandy format or for the summit
that ukraine has proposed
the oce special monitoring mission is
vital
for monitoring the situation in eastern
ukraine
this is why germany's second staff
remains on the ground the smm must be
allowed to carry out its mandate in full
we want to resolve
this crisis by diplomacy
to this end
russia must immediately change its
course of action
first
i urge russia to de-escalate now
to withdraw its troops from ukraine in
particular from the self-proclaimed
entities and the crimean peninsula
as well as from ukraine's borders
second
russia must refrain from any action
which would further fuel the risk of a
full-fledged military conflict with
ukraine
search
i urge rascal to immediately repeal its
decision to recognize the separatist
entities
mr president ladies and gentlemen
do we respect the territorial integrity
and sovereign equality of human member
states
do we stand by the u.n charter
i call on all member states to reaffirm
our commitment to these principles
over ukraine
and beyond
with our allies and partners germany
will spare no effort to find a
diplomatic way forward
we will be steadfast in our support for
ukraine and our support for the u.n
charter
it is a common duty to remain committed
to a rules-based order
to trustful cooperation
to bringing forward a common goal of
lasting peace and stability
we invite every member of this
organization to join these efforts
now ladies and gentlemen is the moment
to speak up
and defend the international order of
the u.n charter against unilateral
aggression
jointly
and decisively i thank you
i thank the minister of state
of the federal foreign office of germany
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
european union
thank you mr president and thank you mr
secretary general for your presence and
for your briefing uh this morning and
for
with the legal moral and political
authority of your office clarifying the
implications of what we are now seeing
on the european continent
and how it relates to the un charter
mr president
i will speak
on behalf
of the european union and its member
states
north macedonia montenegro and albania
bosnia and herzegovina iceland and
norway georgia and monaco align
themselves with this statement
mr president the european union recalls
its unwavering support to the
sovereignty territorial integrity and
independence of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
we strongly condemn the decision by the
president putin to recognize the
non-government-controlled areas of
donetsk and luhansk oblasts of ukraine
as independent entities and the ensuing
decision to send russian troops into
these areas
if there was any
any uncertainty the sector general has
made clear that the decision of the
russian federation is a violation of the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
ukraine and inconsistent with the
principles of the charter of this united
nations
they undermine ukraine's sovereignty and
independence and are a severe breach of
international law and international
agreements including the u.n charter
helsinki final act paris charter and the
budapest memorandum
with this decision
russia is clearly violating the minsk
agreements
the european union strongly condemns
russia's continued aggression against
ukraine including through the
unprecedented military buildup near the
border with ukraine and in the black sea
and through the deployment of combat
forces in and the joint drill drills
with belarus and calls on russia to
de-escalate to abide by international
law and to engage constructively in
dialogue through the established
international mechanisms
the eu is responding to these latest
violations with additional restrictive
measures including on all economic
relations with the non-governmentally
controlled areas as well as designations
against individuals and entities
responsible for undermining the
territorial integrity of ukraine in
coordination with our partners
russia's past and present actions
against ukraine are not a matter just
for ukraine or for europe
they have severe global implications
violations of fundamental principles of
international law and the un charter
directed towards another state
is of serious global concern
these rules apply to all
and permanent members of the security
council have particular responsibility
in upholding the charter
the eu fully subscribes to and for its
part reaffirms our full commitment to
the core principles of european security
enshrined in the u.n charter and the
commitments russia itself has subscribed
to
this includes notably the sovereign
equality and territorial integrity of
states the inviolability of frontiers
refraining from the threat or use of
force and the freedom of states to
choose or change their own security
arrangements
these principles are neither negotiable
nor subject to revision or
reinterpretation
their violation by russia is an obstacle
to a common security space in europe and
threatens the peace and stability in
europe and worldwide what is happening
in ukraine affects the security of each
and every u.n member state we therefore
call on russia to respect the principles
of the charter
to de-escalate and to engage in the kind
of meaningful diplomacy that we have
offered and that the secretary general
has reiterated and supported
mr president we call on russia to
constructively engage in the normandy
format and the trilateral contact group
to achieve the full implementation of
the minsk agreements endorsed by the
security council resolution 2202
russia needs urgently to de-escalate
tensions caused by the military buildup
along its border with ukraine and on
crimea and seize the provocation and
aggressive rhetoric
russia must change course and
constructively contribute to
negotiations in the normandy format and
the trilateral contact group in line
with what was agreed in recent n4
meeting in paris and berlin
we welcome the osce special
representatives attempts to convene
extraordinary sessions of the trilateral
contact group to defuse tensions and we
expect russia to accept the invitation
to such a meeting in the future
we also call on russia to immediately
stop fueling the conflict and remove
russian troops and hardware illegally
deployed in areas currently not under
the control of the government of ukraine
the eu strongly condemns the recent
increase of ceasefire violations as well
as orders for mobilization issued by the
de facto authorities in areas currently
not under control of the government of
ukraine
we condemn the use of heavy weaponry and
recalls that the shelling of civilian
infrastructures represents a clear
violation of the ceasefire the minsk
agreements and international
humanitarian law
the eu commends ukraine's posture and
restraint in the face of continued
provocations and efforts at
destabilization as we've just heard from
this rostrum this morning by the foreign
minister
the eu underlines the role of the osce
as the appropriate forum to address
security concerns of all interested
parties including russia
eu member states are ready to engage in
strengthening the existing mechanisms to
ensure military transparency and
predictability and to support efforts
regarding arms control in particular
within the osce framework
in this regard we urge russia to abide
by its commitments under the vienna
document and notably to provide full
transparency on its military activities
in the region to host visits to the
areas which took the course of concern
to take significant and verifiable steps
to de-escalate the situation and to
provide information on the reported
redeployment of russian units from the
locations of military exercises
we also express our support for the
valuable engagement of the osce special
monitoring mission the smm
and its important impartial monitoring
we're therefore deeply concerned by
russia's continued actions to obstruct
the presence of the smm in the
non-government-controlled areas of
ukraine the smm is mandated to monitor
the entire territory of ukraine within
its international recognized borders
including the autonomous republic of
crimea and the city of sevastopol
we urge russia to respect the mandate of
the smm as agreed by all participating
states and ensure that all restrictions
affecting the mission's work are lifted
immediately
we once again applaud the targeting of
assets of the mission
the volatile securities situation in
eastern europe ukraine has an immense
impact on the civilian population in
particular persons in the most
vulnerable situations living in the
non-government-controlled areas and
along both sides of the contact line
where people are under continuous threat
of shelling and we share a profound
concern for their sufferings
as a result of the conflict 2.9 million
ukrainians are still in need of
humanitarian assistance we call on the
sides to respect international
humanitarian law and guarantee
unhindered and sustained access for
humanitarian actors including unhcr and
other un agencies as well as national
and international ngos to all people in
need
the eu together with its 27 member
states is the biggest donor of
humanitarian aid to ukraine
since the beginning of the conflict the
eu will continue to support humanitarian
organizations
mr president let me turn to the
situation in crimea these days we
commemorate eight years since the
beginning of the hostile russian
political and military actions against
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine leading to the
illegal annexation
of the autonomous republic of crimea and
the city of sevastopol by the russian
federation
this illegal annexation
russia's subsequent actions on the
peninsula and in surrounding waters are
in blatant breach of international law
and of key principles of the rules-based
international order they remain a direct
challenge to international security with
grave implications for the international
law that protects the sovereignty
territorial integrity and unity of all
states
in line with the resolutions of this
general assembly the eu reconfirms its
condemnation of this violation of
international law and continue to
implement its consistent non-recognition
policy of the illegal annexation
including through restrictive measures
together with transatlantic partners
as stated in resolution 68262
the so-called referendum organized by
russia on the crimean peninsula in march
2014 has no legal validity and we recall
the obligation of all states not to
recognize
as lawful any territorial acquisition of
special advantage resulting from
aggression and we call on all
u.n member states to remain steadfast in
their policy of non-recognition of
russia's illegal annexation
we welcome ukraine's efforts to continue
to seek justice using international
legal instruments and courts
the ongoing russian militarization of
the crimean peninsula has a negative
impact on the security situation in the
black sea region and beyond and we call
on russia to reframe from impeding the
lawful exercise of navigational rights
and freedoms to and from the sea of azov
in accordance with international law
we refund the universal and unified
character of the united nations
convention on the law of the sea
we remain seriously concerned about
transfers by the russian federation of
sophisticated weapons systems and
military personnel to the peninsula
since march 2014.
as documented in the reports by the un
high commissioner for human rights
russian citizenship and constriction in
the armed forces of the russian
federation have been imposed on crimean
residents in violation of international
humanitarian law
russian legislative elections have been
illegally held in the legally annexed
crimea and the population census
conducted in an attempt to legitimize
the legal annexation of the peninsula
all these developments are extremely
worrying and hostile the eu remains
deeply concerned about the severe
deterioration of human rights situation
in the crimean peninsula since its
illegal annexation by the russian
federation
residents of the peninsula face
systematic violations of human rights
and fundamental freedoms such as the
rights to freedom of expression religion
of belief and association and the right
to peaceful assembly
arbitrary detentions and convictions
remain systemic in particular the human
rights situation of the crimean tatars
have been targeted targeted
in accordance with the u.n general
assembly resolution 76179
adopted last december it is crucial that
regional and international human rights
monitoring mechanisms as well as
non-governmental human rights
organizations are granted proper and
unimpeded access to the autonomous
republic of crimea and the city of
sevastopol
journalists media workers human rights
defenders and defense lawyers should be
able to work independently and without
undue interference in intimidation
mr president
the eu reforms our commitment to further
support ukraine's resilience including
encountering cybering cyber and hybrid
threats and tackling disinformation the
eu underlines the importance of
ukraine's reform agenda based on
democracy rule of law respect for
international law and human rights
in conclusion mr president let me
reiterate once again our firm belief
that tensions and disagreements must be
resolved through dialogue and diplomacy
and that this issue is not only a matter
of regional concern but of a global
threats and violations of international
law including the u.n charter affect all
member states of the un and all people
of the world i thank you very much
i thank the distinguished representative
of the european union
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
lithuania on behalf of the eight nordic
baltic countries
mr president secretary general
excellencies
i have the honor to speak on behalf of
the eight nordic baltic countries
denmark estonia finland iceland latvia
norway sweden and my own country
lithuania
all our countries have aligned with the
statement of the european union
mr president
despite the repeated calls for serious
de-escalation by the un's secretary
general and recent intensive diplomatic
efforts at all levels russia keeps
dramatically escalating its aggressive
actions against ukraine
we strongly condemn the decision by
president putin to recognize the
non-government-controlled areas of
dunedin and lohan's globalist
of ukraine as independent entities and
the ensuing decision to send
russian troops into these areas under
the pretext of so-called peacekeeping
we call on russia to reverse these
decisions
as clearly stated by u.n secretary
general and political leaders of our
countries these illegal acts further
undermine ukraine's sovereignty and
independence and constitute a severe
breach of international law
and international agreements including
the u.n charter
helsinki final act paris charter and
budapest memorandum
we underlined that russian forces in
donetsk and lughan's globalist of
ukraine would be nothing else that an
invasion of a sovereign state
calling them peacekeepers to quote the
secretary general is the perversion of
the concept of peacekeeping
by these illegal acts russia is breaking
its commitment to work with the normandy
format and the trilateral contact group
in finding a peaceful settlement to the
conflict
it is also violating u.n security
council resolution
2202 which requires full implementation
of the minsk agreements
the russian federation's use of force
against ukraine is completely
unjustified and unacceptable and must be
met with unity firmness and
determination
including through additional sanctions
in solidarity with ukraine
russia's continued aggressive actions
and threats against ukraine and its
recent unprecedented and large-scale
military build-up in ukraine and near
its borders including through deployment
of combat forces in
and the joint drills would be healers
pose a threat
not only to european but also to the
global security
in addition
russia's increased military presence
in the black sea
and in the illegally annexed crimean
peninsula as well as the closure of the
large parts of the black sea and the sea
of azov add to the threat of escalation
also in the maritime sphere
no adherence to international law and
its fundamental principles undermines
the rules-based international order and
effective multilateralism
we underscore the crucial importance of
upholding these principles
including to the right of all states to
the sovereign equality
territorial integrity and political
independence as well as freedom of
states to choose their own security
arrangements
the nordic and baltic countries
stand in full solidarity with ukraine
supporting its territorial integrity
sovereignty and independence within this
internationally recognized borders
russia has a clear and direct
responsibility on the international law
to work to find a peaceful settlement of
the conflict we call on russia to
respect the principles of u.n chapter to
de-escalate and to tuesday engaged in
the meaningful view blah blah see
mr president
in three days we will mark the 8th
anniversary of the illegal annexation of
crimea and the city of sevastopol by the
russian federation
the nordic and baltic countries continue
to condemn this blatant violation of
international law
and remain committed
to implementing the use non-proclamation
policy including through restrictive
measures
we call on un members
member states to consider similar
measures in accordance with the u.n
general assembly the resolution 68-262
we continue to condemn the increasing
militarization of the crimean peninsula
and the severe deterioration of the
human rights situation there
we recall the obligation of all states
not to recognize as lawful any
territorial acquisition or special
advantage resulting from the use of
armed forces
the russia-instigated conflict has
resulted in around 14 000 deaths
1.5 million displaced
countless
damages and suffering of those living on
the both sides of the contact line
furthermore we are witnessing russia's
continued effort of de facto integration
and systematic demographic changes of
the illegally annexed crimea as well as
non-government-controlled areas in
donetsk and luhansk regions of ukraine
including through accelerated issues
issuing of russian passports on the
massive scale to ukrainian citizens and
forced conscription to the russian armed
forces such moves are making the
conflict resolution efforts even more
difficult
we are concerned about reported
arbitrary detentions and the rest
especially of crimean tatars and
ukrainian-speaking minorities
increasing pressure on journalists and
media workers
human rights defenders and other members
of civil society
russia must fully respect international
law including international humanitarian
law and international human rights law
we call for the immediate release
of all illegally detained and imprisoned
persons in the crimean peninsula and in
russia
it is essential
that international organizations and
human rights actors have unhindered
access to the areas currently not under
control of the ukraine
and the crimean peninsula in accordance
with u.n general assembly resolution 76
179 of the 16th december 2021
we urge russia to withdraw its forces
and material from within ukraine
including the crimean peninsula and
non-government-controlled areas of
luhansk and doneness cobles as well as
from areas adjacent to its borders and
to immediately stop fueling the conflict
we reiterate our full support to the
efforts towards peaceful and sustained
sustainable resolution of this conflict
through the established international
mechanisms we commend ukraine for its
constructive approach and urge russia to
assume its responsibility as a party to
the conflict upholding its commitments
abide by the international law and
return to the discussions within the
normandy format and the trilateral
contact group
it is essential that oac special
monitoring mission have free and
unhindered access through ukraine
including the crimean peninsula and
non-government-controlled areas in
donetsk and luhansk oblast of ukraine in
accordance with its mandates we're
deeply concerned regarding the continued
restrictions of the mission's freedom of
movement including security incidents
involving its staffs and assets mr
president the position of nordic and
baltic countries is clear
it is our duty as members of the un to
defend the rules-based international
order
challenges to this order clearly affect
international community as a whole
we urge russia to abide by international
law and uphold its international
commitments
like the secretary general
we recall the obligations on the u.n
charter of all members to refrain from
the threat or use of force and to settle
the international disputes by peaceful
means
we thank the secretary general for his
clear message on russia's aggressive
actions and call for the u.n to continue
efforts to restore respect for the
sovereign sovereignty territorial
integrity political independence and
unity of ukraine with its
internationally recognized borders i
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of lithuania
who spoke on behalf of the eight nordic
baltic countries
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
russian federation
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
them
foreign
is
foreign
foreign
i thank the distinguished representative
of the russian federation
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of japan
mr president
the government of japan has a strong
view
that what is happening
in and around ukraine is not an isolated
problem in europe
but the problem
for the for the entire international
community
and the challenge
to the international order
it goes totally against
the purposes and principles of the u.n
charter
mr president
japan consistently supports the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
russia's decision to recognize the
independence of certain regions of
eastern ukraine
seriously undermines those very
principles
in violation of international law
it is absolutely unacceptable
and japan strongly condemns
the series of recent russian acts
prime minister kishida acting in
lockstep with the international
community has announced sanctioned
measures including the suspension of the
issuance of entry visas and asset freeze
to individuals concerned
japan continues to pay close attention
with serious concern
to the development of the situation
including russia's military buildup
in the armed areas around ukraine's
borders and
its decision regarding the deployment of
its forces outside its territory
tensions
should be de-escalated by the withdrawal
of russian troops
and this is essential to restore the
cause of diplomacy
any threat to a use of force
against the sovereignty and tertiary
integrity of states
goes against the fundamental principles
that underpin
the rules-based international order
it is a clear violation of international
law
and what is at stake for the member
states is the rule of law and the un
charter itself
mr president
japan expresses its solidarity with the
people of ukraine for the hope come true
japan has made its own diplomatic
efforts for a peaceful solution and
supports the efforts of all countries
for a serious diplomatic solution to the
present crisis
before closing
let me reiterate
that uniratel attempts to change the
status quo
by force or coercion
are unacceptable regardless of whatever
they take place wherever they take place
no member states can afford to be a
bystander
japan will continue to work hand in hand
with other partners thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
japan
and now i give the floor
to the distinguished representative of
the united states
thank you mr president
member states of the united nations
we stand at a crossroads in the history
of this body
on monday president putin
announced that russia would recognize as
independent states
the so-called dnr
and lnr regions part of the sovereign
territory of ukraine controlled by
russia's proxies since 2014.
he then ordered russian military forces
under the guise of so-called
peacekeepers
to deploy to these regions
in the hours that followed
secretary general guterres said
this was a violation of the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of ukraine
and inconsistent with the principles of
the charter of the united nations
he he reaffirmed that to us in his
remarks today
in an emergency meeting monday night all
but one member of the security council
called for dialogue and diplomacy which
can only happen
if russia abandons its unprovoked
further aggression
toward ukraine
has russia heeded these calls
no
instead it has responded with additional
actions to undermine ukraine's
sovereignty including mass
disinformation which we just heard again
today
cyber attacks and efforts to create a
false flag pretext
in addition to russia's overwhelming
military buildup of more than 150 000
troops near ukraine's border
russia's actions have only confirmed
what we and other nations have been
warning about
other u.n member states must recognize
the threat before us all today before
it's too late
colleagues
there's no middle ground here
calling for both sides to de-escalate
only gives russia a pass
russia is the aggressor here
history tells us that looking the other
way is ultimately the more costly path
and we need only to look across the past
decade
for an indication
of the path that russia is taking
since 2014
russia has occupied crimea
following its illegal invasion and has
been manufacturing and fueling ongoing
military conflicts in eastern ukraine
in recent years
including president putin's remarks this
week
russian leaders have claimed that
ukraine
is not a real country
they have questioned its right to exist
russia's actions are an unprovoked
violation of international law
of ukraine sovereignty and territorial
integrity and a direct contravention
contradiction of the men's agreements
russia's aggression not only threatens
all of ukraine
but every member state and the un itself
colleagues president putin gave us the
clearest indication of his intentions on
monday when he asked the world to travel
back in time by more than a hundred
years before the united nations even
existed to an age of empires
he asserted that russia can recolonize
its neighbors and that he will use force
he will use force to make a farce
of the united nations
the united states rejects that firmly
this is 2022
we're not going back to an era of
empires and colonies or to the ussr or
the soviet union we have moved forward
and we must ensure as the permanent
representative from kenya said in the
security council on monday night that
the embers of dead empires do not ignite
new forms of oppression and violence
unfortunately the fake reality russia
wants to create is already having real
consequences for the people of ukraine
and for the world
to date
russia's war in eastern ukraine has
already killed more than fourteen
thousand people
nearly three million ukrainians
half of whom are elderly people and
children need food shelter and other
life-saving assistance
and of course ordinary russians should
be asking how many russian lives putin
is willing to sacrifice to feed his
ambitions
if russia continues down this path it
could according to our estimates create
a new refugee crisis
one of the largest facing the world
today with as many as five million more
people displaced by russia's war of
choice and putting pressure on ukraine's
neighbors
and because ukraine is one of the
world's largest wheat suppliers
especially for the developing world
russia's actions could cause a spike in
food prices and lead to even more
desperate hunger in places like libya
yemen and lebanon
the tidal wave of suffering this war
will cause are unthinkable
and then there's the broader threat
that russia's actions up in our
international system make a mockery of
the u n charter and call into question
our most fundamental principles of
sovereignty
diplomacy and territorial integrity
unfortunately despite these terrible
word world altering outcomes russia
appears determined to proceed
together with our partners and allies
president biden has taken decisive
action to make the cost of russia's
actions crystal clear
but as much as we all want russia to
de-escalate and choose the path of peace
that is not our choice to make
this is president putin's war of choice
if he chooses to escalate further
russia and russia alone will bear full
responsibility for what is to come
what we can do together today
is make clear
that russia will pay an even even
steeper price if it continues this
aggression
that responsible countries do not bully
their neighbors into submission
that former empires cannot
lay claim to sovereign and independent
nations
the very first line of the u.n charter
states we are uniting together quote
determined to save succeeding
generations from the scourge of war
this right here right now
is a moment
it is a moment when we can save this
generation and the next from that
terrible fate
colleagues
now is not the time
to sit on the sidelines
now is the time to get off of the
sidelines
let us together show russia that it is
isolated and alone in its aggressive
actions
let us stand fully behind the principles
of sovereignty
political independence and territorial
integrity for ukraine and for all member
states
let us show russia that every other un
member state
believes it is time to de-escalate
to come back to the negotiating table
and to work toward peace
so that ukrainians can live in security
and the tenets of the u.n charter can be
upheld for future generations to come
thank you very much
i thank the distinguished representative
of the united states
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of georgia
mr president
excellencies
my delegation aligns itself with the
statement made by the european union and
in my national capacity i would like to
add the following comment
last year we celebrated 75th anniversary
of the united nations which was created
to save succeeding generations from the
scourge of war but today our generation
and this very united nations and the
rules-based order has come at a crucial
juncture
how the events will unfold
will define not only the future of
security and stability in europe but of
the entire international community
it is deeply alarming that the
international norms and principles that
we all committed to uphold are
repeatedly violated by the russian
federation
a permanent member of the security
council whose primary responsibility is
to do the exact opposite act as the
guardian of peace and security
unfortunately breaching the
international law and undermining
international rules-based order has long
been a marking of russia's aggressive
policy towards its neighboring states
aimed at forcefully redrawing their
borders
and trying to curb their sovereign
choices
my country georgia is no exception here
russia's decision to recognize the
so-called independence of integral parts
of ukraine and sending its military as
the so-called peacekeepers represent
grave violation of the un charter and
the helsinki final act
moreover
they are in breach of russia's own
commitments made under the budapest
memorandum and the minsk agreements
endorsed by the security council
resolution 2202
the georgian government strongly
condemns russia's so-called recognition
of ukraine's territories the so-called
lpr and dpr
let me be clear these decisions as in
the case of russian-occupied georgian
regions shall never be accepted by the
international community
eight years have passed since the
russian aggression against ukraine
annexation of crimea and instigation of
the conflict in donbass the humanitarian
cost alone is tremendous
more than fourteen thousand ukrainian
citizens died while more than thirty
thousand have been injured and almost
half of one and a half million residents
of the occupied areas of ukraine now
live in internal displacement
as we speak another wave of russia's
military aggression against ukraine is
well underway
it is aimed at redrawing ukraine
sovereign borders and the security
repercussions of such actions will go
far beyond
ukraine let me express strong solidarity
dear colleagues aggression against
ukraine is a repetition of the same
pattern of russia's illegal actions that
we saw against my own country
it started with inciting and backing up
puppet regimes in georgia's abkhazia and
skin valley regions
then came a full-scale military
aggression in 2008 under fabricated
pre-tax leading to their illegal
occupation and shortly after signing a
ceasefire agreement instead of
fulfilling obligations undertaken russia
recognized the occupied territories as
sovereign entities thus creating a
launchpad for their factual annexation
as of today in breach of all the
international commitments including
inter rally at the eu mediated 12th of
august 2008 ceasefire agreement
russian federation continues its illegal
and provocative actions toward the
occupied regions of georgia conducting
so-called borderization process which in
effect is nothing less than a continuous
aggression and a creeping annexation
humanitarian consequences of the
aforementioned actions are appalling
given unbearable human rights situation
and the conditions the civilian
population women and children have to
endure
we are seeing the very same playbook in
action in ukraine
this pattern of behavior brazenly
undermines the entire international
rules-based order
poses grave threat to regional and
global peace and security and are
inconsistent with the ways how
responsible states should act in the
21st century
it is no longer about ukraine or georgia
or other countries neighboring russia
peace and security in europe and beyond
are at stake
silence and acquiescence to land
grabbing today is tantamount to a crime
before the generations to come
distinguished colleagues
we should be united in defending the
very fundamentals of the international
rules based order
and first and foremost the u.n charter
helsinki final act and charter of paris
for new europe
with this in mind we call on russia to
reverse its illegal recognition to
immediately withdraw its military from
ukraine and its borders and abide by the
international law we call upon russia to
do the same with regard to the occupied
georgian regions
and in conclusion georgia strongly
supports ukraine's european and
euro-atlantic aspirations and reiterates
its unwavering support for the
independent sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
including crimea and donbass and
ukraine's navigational rights in its
territorial waters i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of
georgia
and now i invite the distinguished
representative
turkey to take the floor
mr president
mr secretary general
it has been eight years since the
occupation of crimea
since the first day the international
community has maintained a resolute
position
we never recognize the illegal
annexation
and we have always supported ukraine's
independence territorial integrity
sovereignty and political unity within
its internationally recognized borders
this is our legal and moral obligation
mr president today we face a new act of
aggression this time against another
part of ukrainian territory
this is totally unacceptable
we reject russia's decision to recognize
the so-called donetsk and luhansk
republics and send in additional troops
it is illegal and illegitimate
it is in contravention of tibinsk
agreements and constitutes a flagrant
violation of ukraine's political unity
sovereignty and territorial integrity
mr president
we do not need nor do we want a new war
in our region
we call upon russia to reverse its
decision and return to diplomacy and
dialogue on the basis of the minsk
agreements
this is the only way that will take us
away from the precipice
therefore we call for restraint and
common sense we urge the parties to get
together around the negotiation table
without delay
as a neighbor to both parties we are
ready to facilitate this process and
host technical and or high-level
meetings we also welcome president
zalensky's proposal for a meeting
between p5 turkey germany and ukraine
finally we continue to support the osce
special monitoring mission led by
ambassador alex cevik
mr president i am obliged to repeat
today ukraine a founding member of the
united nations is faced with yet another
act of aggression
and the global community is faced with
yet another threat to regional and
international peace and security
but above all this is an aggression
against the fundamental principles of
international law and the u.n chanter
make no mistake we all need the
rules-based international order it is
our duty as member states to defend
legality it is our obligation to ensure
that conflicts are resolved through
peaceful means
we must make sure
that
the founding principles of the un are
upheld
this is
the only way to save ourselves from the
scourge of war thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of turkey
and i will give the floor to
distinguished representative of costa
rica
your president
organization
is
foreign
obligatory
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
foreign
is
i thank the distinguished representative
of costa rica
okay
and i'll give the floor to the
distinguished representative of mexico
senor
[Music]
resolutions
trace
esperamos
pacifica
italian
i thank the distinguished representative
of mexico
and i'll give the floor to the
distinguished representative of france
stability
and europe
contact
utilize this these instruments available
to them one of them is
the significant increase of humanitarian
assistance
to ukraine under the circumstances
second uh
we put on that we reminded the
united nations about our request
of 20 and 15 to consider
uh launching and peace operation in
ukraine
and this is there is a way to do that
without the u.n security council
decision based on the u.n general
assembly resolution
so i'm certain that
if there is a will there is a way
and we will be working with the united
nations on
making sure
that the will
is there and we find the way
to
[Music]
put pressure on russia
minister you go to talks with americans
yesterday uh you met secretary blinken
you met president biden you never
comment on that until now could you tell
what is the main message you got from
americans
the united uh both not even both but
my three main counterparts uh
my three main interlocutors in
washington president biden state
secretary blinken
and secretary of defense austin
they all conveyed three very clear
messages first
the united states will stand
by ukraine
whatever happens whatever rush whatever
scenario russia to prefer will prefer
second
ukraine will the united states will
continue to provide ukraine with
defensive weapons
to
further build our capacity to defend our
country
and i would like to assure you that
we would be happy
if we never have
to
pick up those weapons and use them in
the battlefield
we want peace
but if russia attacks
we have to be equipped
to fight back
and the third message was that
u.s sanctions
will be continued
there will be more sanctions on russia
more painful sanctions on russia
and they will be done in close
coordination with the allies with the
u.s allies in europe and other parts of
the world in order to ensure
the maximum efficiency of these
sanctions
so this will these are the political
messages but
i assure you that in our talks we were
very specific
about the ways
how these messages
will be turned into actions in the
coming days and we appreciate for
example the sanctions which were already
imposed by the united states canada
united kingdom the european union some
other countries but this is not enough
and our partners should not wait
for russian rockets to hit ukrainian
soil
or russian planes to cross into our
airspace
to impose the new wave of sanctions
sanctions make sense
when they deter
russia from further action
so the time for the next wave of
sanctions has come
we
are in a very dynamic situation and
every day matters
thank you stephanov
new york um this is a follow-up and
another question
um so can we say that you after the
meeting in washington you are satisfied
completely satisfied because there were
reactions
in washington by the other party that
say that president biden was too weak in
its rare in his reaction towards russia
so i would like to respond to this and
then today what you heard so far
uh the speeches there will be more china
will speak are you satisfied the
reaction is russia isolated enough in
this building at the moment
i will be satisfied when the the last
russian soldier withdraw from ukrainian
territory
until it doesn't happen i cannot be
fully satisfied
but what we saw
yesterday and the day before
in washington in london in brussels in
in ottawa
was a clear demonstration that the
united that our partners understand
clearly one simple fact
this is not only an attack on ukraine
this is an attack on the existing world
order
and the fact that they imposed the first
wave of sanctions is appreciated
the decision of the german
government to
hold north stream 2
is appreciated
but this is not enough to stop putting
and this is why the message that i
received yesterday in washington that
what what was already done is not the
end of story and more actions will be
taken and we will be looking forward to
it
and my message is simple that do not
wait too long
you have to act now literally every day
decisions have to be adopted
more sanctions have to be imposed
more weapons have to be supplied more
diplomatic efforts have to be
undertaken
minister i would like to come back to
young topic actually because we're here
you already mentioned about the tools
practical tools that can be implanted
implemented by you and to help ukraine
can you be more specific about deadlines
about conditions when we can talk about
like for example strengths of
humanitarian aid to ukraine or like
peacekeeping missions that actually
everybody is expected to see thank you
again deadline
for every
action aimed at this at preventing the
war is now
we all have our bureaucracies
national governments international
organizations they are
eventually essentially bureaucratic
structures and we understand that there
are procedures
so this the sooner these procedures are
launched the better it is
the situation deteriorates every day
and
no one can allow waiting until it's too
late as foreign minister i
do my best
to avoid a situation when the world
reacts to the war
only after ukrainian blood will be
spilled
i do not want my
co-patriots
to pay their lives and sufferings
for the reluctance
for the consciousness
for the inability to act
by other governments or international
organizations this is why i'm saying
clearly here in the united nations and i
said it yesterday in washington
we appreciate what has been done but
this is not enough more needs to be done
as soon as possible
prime minister thank you so much for
this availability
my question goes to the message that the
russian ambassador gave at the end of
his speech he said that the russian
military will be in charge of
peacekeeping uh and they will not be
softy safety with the violators
what can you um
say about that type of message
especially after the secretary general
was very clear about his concern of the
use of the word peacekeeping to refer to
the russian military on the dumbass area
i think the secretary general should
come out and say
a very simple thing
russia must stop abusing the word
peacekeepers
and the concept of peacekeeping
enshrined in the united nations charter
this is exactly what we are talking
about
russia tries to replace the u.n with
itself
they want to have a free hand to decide
uh
how to maintain peace the way they want
to maintain peace and usually when they
say that we want we
we want to maintain peace they speak
about another act of aggression
and
the
use of the word peacekeepers may work
for russian audience
but it shouldn't
uh
mislead the world and the world should
clearly debunk this disinformation and
speak openly this is the time to call
spay the spate
speaking about uh
classic diploma diplomatic narratives do
not work anymore
calling on both sides to de-escalate or
making statements not mentioning russia
doesn't help anyone except russia
because it creates space for russia to
move forward and to
come to a conclusion that in the end
everything will be fine because if they
are afraid
to call us by name now
under this critical circumstances
then they will tolerate any kind of
behavior
but
again
i will repeat it the the fact that you
mentioned about the reference to
peacekeepers it's another manifestation
of russia's
ignorance
of russia ignoring the united nations of
russia attacking the fundamental
concepts of the united nations
and i'm not exaggerating what i'm saying
that
what russia is doing now is an attempt
to make the united nations follow the
path of the league of nations we all saw
it in history
and it's for our generation who learned
history who read history books who know
diplomacy
to avoid
the the reputation of this scenario no
one can say now this has never happened
before we we didn't we didn't realize
where it would take us to
there will be no such excuse everyone
perfectly understands what is happening
here
and the attack on the secretary general
is by the russian ambassador is
unprecedented
and if
the united nations tolerate such an
attack
this it will be only the united nations
who will uh suffer the most and who will
be who will end up discredited and
unrespected
thank you uh thank you uh mr foreign
minister and thank you for this
availability and welcome to new york
there has been a lot of concern about
how president biden described the
invasion by russia calling it the start
of an invasion
just a follow-up to what you mentioned
did you talk to him about
how he might have moved the goalpost in
imposing sanctions
on
russia how for months he threatened to
impose those hard-hitting sanctions and
now there is talk that perhaps throwing
russia out of the swift financial system
might be out of the question that was
the nuclear option and my second
question is after what you heard from
the russians today at the united nations
general assembly under what circumstance
would you sit down at the same table
with your russian counterpart sergey
lavrov for some kind of negotiation
about this matter thank you
as far as i understand
president biden
his idea is to impose sanctions
by waves
and we accept this approach
but
but what i said to the president
yesterday
what i said to other interlocutors and
during my meetings here in the united
nations
is that these waves should come one
after another
again
we appreciate decisions already taken
but they're not enough
to prevent russia from
changing their mind to prevent president
putin from changing their might
this is not enough
and
we
should not allow
russia the slightest possibility to
think
that the unbearable sanctions which were
promised to them
will be bearable
now uh on minister lavrov uh
i was appointed uh as foreign minister
in march 2020
and since then there were numerous
attempts
to arrange
our
meeting in normandy formats i reach out
to speak bilaterally on the phone to him
but he never picks up the phone
he never agrees
to
he never agreed to meet in the normandy
format
he
is talented enough
to
find all kind of excuses why he
shouldn't show up
so i don't care about him
if
he
is ready
to
convince
president putin
to stop this madness
we are ready to sit down i'm open
if he just uh follows the
uh
if he just reinforces the narratives of
president putin
and chooses war to diplomacy
that's his choice that's his choice
and he will pay for that
hello i'm kauri oshida from nikkei
japanese business news japan along with
some western nations have imposed
sanctions on russia over ukraine uh
there are a lot of japanese media here
today can we get a reaction from you on
these movements and from the
announcement of potential additional
sanctions by japan
we expect
a stronger
reaction
by japan and a stronger action by japan
for a number of a number of reasons
which i'm not going to elaborate on
today
i believe japan must be vitally
interested
in
not allowing russia to crush the
existing world order
based on rules
and not to demonstrate by its example
to others
that this is a path of success
and the one who dares
eventually succeeds
and this is the
this are the global consequences
of the russian aggression against
ukraine
because if we are not able to defend
very simple fundamental principles
in europe
it means that we are not able to defend
them in any other part of the world
so a stronger reaction by japan is most
welcome
and i understand that some countries
may
think this is not our fight
we have to wait and see how it ends up
some believe that we have excellent
relations with russia why should we put
them at stake
but this is not about ukraine
this is really
about
the destruction the destruction of the
world order
and they every nation who has this kind
of consideration should understand
simple fact now russia tries to behave
nicely to them to keep them under
control
and avoid
additional pressure coming from new
corners
but if russia succeeds
the next step
will for russia will be to build their
relations with those countries from a
dominant position
because they will demonstrate that this
is what we're capable to do
and this is where we are capable we we
can uh be be successful so every country
should be mindful of that consequence
russia may smile to you today
like they did with minsk agreements for
seven years they have been they were
convincing everyone that minsk
agreements is the
only and
fundamental basis for diplomatic
solution
they were saying on every corner that uh
minsk agreements were endorsed by the
u.n security council resolution this is
a sacred document
that everyone has to
focus on
but one morning they changed their plan
and they abandoned everything it's it's
crazy a permanent member of the united
nations security council killed the
document
endorsed by the united nations security
security council resolution which they
uh
supported and had been convincing
everyone to to follow it so the mood the
attitude can change in a day and every
country should understand that every
country should understand that making
compromises comes at a price
to all
thank you have a good day stay safe
okay
is
[Music]
foreign
wow
[Music]
coming
thank you
thank you
so
is
we strongly condemn the recognition by
russia of the so-called donetsk and
lohan's people's republics
and its decision to move troops into
ukraine
under what they call peacekeeping but
anyone else who understands the meaning
of language would call war making
they're not peacekeepers
they're soldiers who are there
to
invade
their actions violate several treaties
and international agreements to which
russia is a signatory including
the budapest accords the minsk
agreements and of course the charter
these come with obligations obligations
that russia is clearly
rejecting as demonstrated today canada
and the international community are
united and steadfast in our support for
ukraine and for its people
we're implementing responsive measures
including economic sanctions
if russia further escalates
we will follow with more severe measures
russia and its acolytes can spin and can
contort all they want
but the violations of international law
are theirs
the loss of life the wounding the pain
the suffering are all their
responsibilities
as it's been said this is president
putin's choice
we shall respond to any further
violations of the u.n charter
collectively with our allies and with
great determination
it is never too late
to stop
it's never too late to make a turn to
diplomacy to dialogue and to negotiation
together with our partners in europe in
nato and the osce
canada has made it very clear and i
repeat today
we are prepared
to talk directly about mutual reductions
and threats to the peace of europe
to ensure peace prosperity and progress
for all peoples living in this region
that has in this past century
known too much hardship too much tragedy
too much loss of life
we are steadfast in our commitment to
ukraine's sovereignty
territorial integrity
and independence
it's clear that the russian federation's
actions directly threaten
this sovereignty
this territorial integrity of ukraine
and undermined the entire rules-based
international order
russia's hostile actions have to stop
ukraine
is not a mistake
ukraine
is a sovereign nation
its autonomy must be respected and its
territorial integrity restored
it is a solemn and considered decision
of a people
who have sought freedom and prosperity
on their own terms
most of us have referred
to president putin's speech of monday
i noticed that my colleague from the
russian federation did not
but in that speech it's clear
he denied the existence of the other
and when he did that
he made it apparent to the whole world
that this is not about nato
this is not about the european union
this is about the existence and the
right to existence
of a member state
of this organization
mr president
each and every member
state that is here
we all each and every one of us has an
obligation
to uphold the territorial integrity
of other states
to oppose invasions
and to insist on the peaceful resolution
of disputes
that's what we've all signed up for
we didn't sign up for it just for
ourselves
we didn't say this applies to us but it
doesn't apply to anyone else
it applies to all of us
no matter how big
or how small you may be
it applies to each and every
one of us
no nation
no matter how powerful it may be
can take the law into its own hands
no nation has the right
to use its might
to destroy
everyone else's rights
speaking as a proud canadian i can say
we work for peace with justice in korea
we worked hard
during the suez crisis in 1956.
and again when we said there was no
legal basis for the invasion of iraq in
2003
these were not easy decisions
they were not necessarily popular in all
in all quarters or even among some of
our allies
but they were based on a powerful belief
in law
in rules
in common decency
and in multilateralism
that is now
embedded
in our bones
we need to remember
that invasion and war bring with them
terrible losses
and terrible hardships
there is no cause for celebration and
triumph in these wars
there's only the squalor the poverty
and the heartache
of irreparable loss
there's been much talk about legacies
let's be clear
that will be the only legacy
of those who are responsible
for this entirely avoidable
conflict
all those countries formerly under the
yoke of
tyranny communism empire
they share this right with ukraine
canada's history and our proud
association with all the people of
eastern europe
have led us to this point
we are partners
in peace
we are partners in the quest for
security
and prosperity
and partners in the struggle for a world
bound together
by peaceful friendly relations among
nations
and a common commitment to mark to
democracy
and the rule of law
mr president in closing
i would say this
in the darkest days of world war ii
it is said that a representative of the
united states government
harry hopkins
was having a meeting with winston
churchill
and at the end of that meeting he said
wither thou goest
i will go
wither thou largest
i will lodge
thy people shall be my people
and so canada says to ukraine
and to all those who are challenged
wither thou goest
we will go
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of canada for your statements
and i'll give the floor to the
distinguished representative of poland
mr president
distinguished delegates
we are gathered in this chamber because
we the peoples of united nations
all and each of us
have pledged to the un charter
to i quote
reaffirm faith
in fundamental human rights
the dignity and wealth of the human
persons
in the equal rights of the men and women
and all nations
large and small
and as secretary general rightly said
u.n
charter is not a a la carte menu
we are gathered in this chamber today
to preserve these ideals
and to protect the positive developments
in the world's history
that occurred during the 77 years of our
organization has existed
nobody
should be allowed to reverse the course
of the history
and to question our common achievements
there is no return to the world from
before the united nations
the world of imperialism colonialism and
the superiority of one country over
another
and yet today
sadly enough
we are witness of such actions against
ukraine
with russia openly questioning
the right of a statehood of a fellow
member state
russian recent actions have further
compounded the deteriorating human
rights and humanitarian situation in
non-government-controlled territories of
crimea and eastern ukraine
reported widespread cases of arbitrary
detentions torture and ill-treatment of
detainees as well as a violation of
human freedoms fundamental rights and
these areas are extremely worrying
it seems like we have been driven to the
very brink of a major security crisis
whose scale might be unprecedented of
proportion
in this situation
we cannot and we will not remain silent
poland calls today for every member
state of this respect organization
to clearly reiterate the commitment to
operate within the letter in the spirit
of the chart of the united nations
article 2 of the document stipulates
clearly and i quote again
all members shall refrain in their
international relations from the threat
of or use of force against a territorial
integrity or political independence of
any state end of quote
there is no place for indifference here
we call all in each member state to
strongly condemn all acts of aggression
and continuing policies of feta company
pursued by russia
this aggression must stop
and your russian forces must be
withdrawn
we must assertively deplore such
manifestations of neo imperialism and
possessiveness
having learned from our history
poland stands with those who choose
freedom over bondage
the rules of international law over
brutal force
and peace over conflict
therefore we shall continue to firmly
stand by our neighbors ukraine and its
people
we support ukrainian sovereignty and
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
we strongly believe in the right of
every state to pursue its own foreign
policy including the freedom of choice
of alliances and partnership
distinguished delegates
the world would be better a safer place
if all countries respected the
fundamental rights of fellow member
states
today we cry out stop denying them to
ukraine
and stop denying them in so many other
troubled places around the world
despite recent setbacks poland believes
in diplomacy as a mediation being the
only path of peaceful resolution of
conflicts therefore as the current
chairmanship in office of the
organization of security and cooperation
in europe
we have proposed to launch a new
initiative called renewed european
security dialogue
we offer a good services to make it
success
distinguish delegates mr president
history has not ended
let's move it forward together
let's not allow any other resentments or
past frustrations to hold you back
thank you very much
i thank the distinguished representative
of poland
and i'll give the floor to the
distinguished representative of croatia
mr president
croatia aligns itself with the statement
delivered by the european union and i
will make a few additional remarks in my
national capacity
croatia reinforms unwavering
support to the independence
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
in this spirit we echo
secretary general's statement on ukraine
on monday and yesterday
we
reject
russia's decision to recognize the
self-proclaimed regions of donetsk and
lukansk
as an act in clear violation of
international law from the u.n charter
to the minsk agreements
this
regrettable step
is
gravely undermining efforts for
diplomatic solution to the crisis
we reiterate croatia's consistent and
principled position of non-recognition
of the illegal annexation of ukraine's
autonomous republic of crimea and the
city of sevastopol
we also
continue to be worried about the
militarization of the crimean peninsula
as well as by further attempts to
restrict freedom of navigation through
the current strait
including to and from the sea of azov
croatia consistently supports a peaceful
resolution to the conflict in eastern
ukraine by diplomatic means
we reiterate our full support for the
efforts of the normandy format the
trilateral contact group and the
organization
for security and cooperation in europe
as well as the other diplomatic
initiatives and missions
now is the time to engage constructively
towards a sustainable and peaceful
solution with a view to the full
implementation of the minsk agreements
we also remain deeply concerned with
reports of serious violations and
continuous deterioration of human rights
and humanitarian situations in eastern
ukraine as well as in crimea
we continue to support
critical protection monitoring reporting
and advocacy work
of the un high representative for human
rights and the u.n human rights
monitoring mission in ukraine
we are concerned with numerous ceasefire
violations and support the work of osce
special monitoring mission
and in current circumstances
particularly ask russia to ensure the
personal safety of the monitors and to
allow unhindered implementation of their
duties under the agreed mandate
after eight years of conflict the
deteriorating security situation in
eastern ukraine has dire consequences
for all ukrainians
especially millions of civilians living
in and near the conflict zone
distinguished delegates
we need no further threatening
escalation what is required is immediate
return to dialogue based on
international law in particular the u.n
charter and the minsk agreements
the relevant
general assembly resolution on ukraine
as well as the recommendation contained
in the reports of the united nations
human rights monitoring mission in
ukraine
i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of croatia
and i'll give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
netherlands
thank you mr president the kingdom of
the netherlands aligns itself with the
statement made by the european union and
i would like to make some additional
remarks in my national capacity
mr president we meet at the time when as
the secretary general said the u.n and
the international system are being
tested
the decision of the russian federation
to recognize the so-called independence
of
and sent troops to the separatist
controlled territories in ukraine is a
violation of the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine
it is also a violation of the u.n
charter and of the minsk agreements
endorsed by the security council
we can only see these actions by russia
as a deliberate choice to further
escalate an already volatile situation
the netherlands strongly condemns these
acts and has responded firmly in close
coordination with our partners
any further escalation will be met with
a similarly firm response
we call on russia to reverse its illegal
decisions to immediately withdraw its
troops and to engage seriously and in
good space in dialogue with ukraine to
find a diplomatic solution
mr president unfortunately this is not a
new situation
russian violation of international law
in ukraine already started eight years
ago
the illegal annexation of crimea and the
ongoing destabilizing role of russia in
donbass go directly against article 2 as
just quoted by the permanent
representative of canada
like many others i therefore reiterate
my country's strong commitment to the
sovereignty political independence unity
and territorial integrity of ukraine
within its international recognized
borders so including crimea and its in
adjacent waters
mr president
the events of the past eight years have
already come at considerable cost for
the affected population
as the secretary general said in a
situation of conflict it is the citizens
that suffer first and suffer most
we therefore thank the secretary general
and all uh un agencies for their
continuous support to the people
throughout through its humanitarian
operations and human rights efforts
we also thank the osce special
monitoring mission for the indispensable
work of their monitors
as the ohr reports clearly show the
human rights situation on the illegally
occupied crimean peninsula and in the
non-government-controlled areas in
eastern ukraine remains deeply
concerning
residents of the peninsula face
systematic restrictions of fundamental
freedoms such as freedom of expression
religion or belief and association and
the right to peaceful assembly
the kingdom of the netherlands urgently
calls on russia to respect the human
rights on the crimean peninsula and to
allow full access for human rights
monitors
mr president when talking about the
occupied territories in ukraine i cannot
but touch upon flight mh17 that was shot
down over the east of ukraine on the
17th of july 2014.
this terrible tragedy caused the death
of 298 innocent civilians from 17
different countries including 196 of my
own compatriots
since that day
the netherlands has together with many
international partners called for truth
justice and accountability this is what
the victims and their next of kin
deserve
the start in my march 2020 of the
criminal trial has been a very important
step towards finding the truth
establishing justice and holding those
responsible to account
at the same time the criminal
investigation continues and we call upon
all countries including russia to fully
cooperate with this investigation in
line with u.n security council
resolution 2166
let me end by reiterating that
sustainable peace and stability in the
region will only be possible if the
russian federation moves away from the
current path of escalation by fully
respecting the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine and
returning to the path of dialogue and
negotiations i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of netherlands
and i'll give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
switzerlands
pacific conflict
group the contact trilateral
obligations
humanitarian
i thank the distinguished representative
of switzerland
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of china
[Music]
i think the distinguished representative
of china
and i'll give the floor to the
distinguished representative of new
zealand
mr president colleagues
today's annual u.n general assembly
debate on ukraine
takes place at a critical time for
ukraine
for europe and for our international
community
consistent with the un charter
and as members of the general assembly
it is our responsibility to do all that
we can do
to avoid the deadly consequences of war
we know only too well that the cost of
conflict falls on civilians
a disproportionate burden
carried by women children and the
elderly
death
injury
displacement
loss of critical infrastructure
reduced access to health care and
education and the curtailment of human
rights and freedoms
this is why new zealand stands so
strongly opposed to russia's deliberate
and provocative actions taken in the
last few days
russia's actions represent a clear
breach of ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
and a sharp violation of international
law and amongst agreements
new zealand strongly supports the
sovereign right of any state to
determine its own future
including in terms of its security
relationships
we have been consistent in expressing
our strong support for ukraine's
territorial integrity and sovereignty
and international diplomatic efforts to
find a peaceful solution
there is no basis under international
law for the recognition of the pro
self-proclaimed don people's republic
and luhans people's republic
their recognition by russia and the
deployment of russian troops into the
danes and luhans regions
undermines diplomatic efforts towards a
de-escalation of the crisis between
russia and ukraine
new zealand is deeply concerned that
this is a calculated act
by russia to create a pretext for an
invasion of ukraine
everyone in this chamber knows that a
military invasion is an act of
aggression
and a violation of one of the most
fundamental principles of international
law
we join the secretary general in being
deeply concerned about the perversion of
the concept of peacekeeping
we agree that when troops of one country
enter the territory of another country
without its consent they are not
peacekeepers at all
by the self-proclaimed republics
and in russian occupy crimea are very
troubling
new zealand joins the international
community and calling for human rights
violations in the donbass region to
cease
we encourage russia
ukraine and other parties to intensify
dialogue
including through a return to the
normandy format
with a focus on bringing an urgent
de-escalation of tension
we call on russia and all parties to
respect international humanitarian law
and we call on russia to commit to
dialogue to resolve its security
concerns
to act in the interests of peace and the
principles of the united nations
and to act consistently with its
responsibilities as a permanent member
of the united nations security council
russia's continued efforts to undermine
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine
represent one of the most significant
risks to international peace and
security for decades
the impacts of such a conflict will not
be confined to europe
it will further destabilize the
international community at a time when
geos
geostrategic uncertainty is already high
the international rules system
is under pressure
and the global economy remains fragile
all compounded by the impacts of the
covert 19 pandemic
this is a dangerous time
we are at a critical juncture
but it is one where we believe that
diplomacy must prevail
in preventing a conflict that would have
tragic consequences for ukraine
for europe
for russia and for the world
new zealand supports the secretary
general's rallying call to resolve this
crisis without further bloodshed
we stand ready to support international
diplomatic efforts to de-escalate the
crisis in ukraine in any way we can
thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of new zealand
and now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of italy
mr president
italy aligns itself with the statement
of the european union and wishes to add
the following remarks of its
own we strongly condemn the decision by
the russian federation to recognize the
independence of the self-proclaimed
republics of donetsk and lugansk and to
deploy russian forces in the dombass
region
these acts are unacceptable violations
of ukraine's democratic sovereignty and
territorial integrity are inconsistent
with the principles of the charter of
the united nations and contradict the
minsk agreements endorsed by the
security council and of which the
russian federation is a signatory party
the eu has already responded to these
violations with additional restrictive
measures including on economic relations
and trade with the non-governmental
controlled areas
in the financial sphere with asset
freeze of some banks and restrictions on
sovereign debt as well as against
individuals and entities responsible for
undermining the territorial integrity of
ukraine
in line with u.n general assembly
resolution 68-262
italy also reaffirms its known
recognition of the illegal annexation of
the crimea peninsula and reiterates its
unwavering support and commitment to
ukraine's independence sovereignty and
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
this position has been stated by italy
also in its capacity as the current
presidency of the council of europe
we call on russia to reconsider its
decisions to de-escalate tensions to
withdraw military forces from ukraine's
territory and to fully abide by its
international commitments
as the secretary general whose efforts
we appreciate pointed out yesterday and
today we need the escalation now and now
is the time to return to negotiations
we urge russia to pursue dialogue on
security issues through the u.s russia
strategic stability dialogue the nato
russia council and the osce
we commend the renewed osc european
security dialogue launched by the polish
osce chairmanship in office and we
encourage russia to engage
constructively in it
while the offer of dialogue remains
standing any further military initiative
against ukraine would trigger an
additional united and firm response
mr president after almost eight years of
conflict and in light of the latest
developments we are more and more
concerned about the condition of the
civilian population in ukraine
which continues the pair the heaviest
burden
it is of the utmost importance to
provide effective and unhindered
assistance to those in need and to help
preserve the economic and financial
stability of ukraine which is being
further undermined by the current crisis
environment
in this regard italy intends to support
ukraine with an amount of around 110
million euros in eight credit and grants
building on the support that it has
provided since 2014 italy remains
committed to do its part together with
european partners and in full solidarity
with ukrainian people
mr president italy will continue to be
actively engaged in close coordination
with its european partners and with its
allies
to promote a peaceful solution to this
crisis and to avert a conflict at the
heart of europe which would have
disastrous humanitarian and economic
consequences i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of italy we have heard the last speaker
in the debate on this item for this
morning
we shall hear the remaining speakers at
3 pm today in this hall the meeting is
adjourned
you